today's topic young jock just to give
you guys context young jock is a former
rapper hits back in the day driving for
uber and this conversation like you
driving go
I really think this late yeah oh my
manager first I'm gonna need to cool off
no no you don't have to cool off I think
they want to hear you right now
he's doing money in a legit way and we
have to dog him for that it makes me
think of that time when there was the
actor that used to play in The Cosby
Show that was bagging groceries muffles
taking pictures of him and like Oh life
they just try to provide for their
family the best way they can
what is so wrong with that yo famous
people given it's not always gonna last
people giveth and people take us and I'm
sickest at the audacity of people of
just dong EP before he's earning money
you're toxic when you're doing that
you're rad super wack he's just doing
the best he can you'll leave people beat
everybody as a normal person
Oh see if I make it I make billions of
dollars I could no longer eat a taco two
days and get a taco for two dollars
because that's not [ __ ] enough for you
but who is Deeping you a ride where's
your car where's your right you're in
him stop disrespecting the man for
giving you a ride who raised you the
goddamn walls
ask that question again who raised you
what is wrong with you Wow
you wanna step in someone's car
disrespect him because he's driving
mostly balling passing by at front of
you and it's whatever y'all you need to
get your priorities straight that is
done that is corny [ __ ] to do catch a
ride shut up go back home where's your
right it's
Lane it's low life low class low low
everything your Lolo disgusting and
despicable like whatever you think
you're talking to
I even swallow me do you think you are
you know cards rabid mother hitching a
ride over asking
taxi mandoline mother and you won't be
like who you suppose be big you fellow
but behind the chicken what were you on
nah be that is dumb it's like nobody can
catch the brain what he would have been
better if you were to sell crack okay he
was cool when he was talking about drugs
but now that he's doing normal he fell
off is that what Wow Wow
Wow go ahead I'm good
I'm just gonna be back here thinking
about my life I just got a bunch of
thing and I need that I said I mean you
know I mean many things take your time
take your time I'm lovin interrupt you
leave this is disappointing on a few
different levels first for you to say
this stuff to him incredibly
disrespectful unnecessary and then
secondly to film it and to post it
online so you can clown him to the world
it's so incredibly sad because the only
thing he's doing is making an honest
living and oftentimes I think in the
black community especially most of our
role models you know are in the rap game
or athletes or all these other things
and when we have someone making on
honest living the phrase that we use is
you fell off you have messed up in life
because you have a regular job you know
it's like the same reason I get mad when
I see people treat you know cleaners raw
terribly or whatever like people who do
service industry jobs when I see them
getting treated terribly it makes my
blood boil
not only because my mom raised me from
that money but because I know how hard
they work it's an honest living and I
would never denigrate it doesn't matter
how much income I have I don't care what
kind of outside owned if I ever had
someone working an industry service and
they were offering me a service I would
never think of talking to them as if
they are less than because without them
there is no me without them doing that
work you don't get to enjoy the luxuries
of life so don't denigrate what they do
because it is absolutely essential and
there is nothing nothing wrong you don't
got to be on YouTube cracking jokes to
be a decent person you don't got to be
you know bawling you don't got to be
doing rap music you don't got to be
doing entertainment work we can all make
an honest living and really contribute
to society in a meaningful way so it's
just sad to see people's mindset there
and they think that this mindset is so
common that they're gonna post it online
other people are gonna agree with them
you know I don't
this I just don't and you know when you
are in the entertainment business
industry when young jock was part of it
that was a time when most record labels
were extremely predatory when they used
to steal all of their artists is money
oh they field so when you know that and
you know someone maybe on a hard times
financially for them to go see chronic
honest work instead of you know doing
what a lot of artists do which is either
turn to drug abuse or to crime I'm happy
that he's doing something that's an
honest living
but here's the other side of it maybe
he's retired from all that work and he
just likes contributing in a different
way
prank my mom should be retired right now
but she likes working
she likes moving she likes being
involved my dad my dad retired at 69 hmm
because he's like not good I'm not doing
what I do I'll stop that when I'm tired
she still works he's not he's done now
but the doctor will call them sometimes
to be like if you want to do a shift you
don't want to do [ __ ] like that yeah it
could be like it's important for us to
not discard people or to denigrate
whatever work they wanted to because you
don't know the reasons why they may be
doing it so let's be encouraging let's
be empathetic let's be understanding
let's support each other let's
congratulate each other a cuz you do an
honest work I respect that too many of
us are glamourizing this entertainment
life thinking that it's all glitz and
glamour I want to retire on a beach with
thousands of women by my side it's not
all that there's something rewarding
about doing honest work so I'm just
disappointing the person but I am very
optimistic because most of the response
towards that person has been condemning
them for the comments they made poor Jon
Chuck so that's always beautiful to see
tell Jon I say y'all congratulations to
you brother because you're setting a
good example for the youth and I
encourage everyone else to know that
having honest work is nothing to be
ashamed of actually in fact it makes you
better
you wonder why it makes you better to
have honest work because you're not
giving in to the temptation of easy
money
you're not giving in to the temptation
of ruining your communities for fast
cash so those are my general
it's anything else I feel what I feel
great
alright leave your comments below let us
know what you think sir I said what I
said you fell off
[Music]
you